[Music]
so the kind of the goal here is to just
walk through like a really simple
use case of plumber tableau to highlight
a couple of things one
how it relates to plumber and how it
kind of extends what plumber can already
do
and then the other piece here is to just
kind of showcase like what
what is plumber tableau trying to solve
from the developer perspective so as an
as an r user what what do i get out of
this tool and then the other side is
like as a as a tableau developer tableau
user how do i leverage something that's
been developed in plumber tableau like
what's the what's the um
workflow and what's the pattern for
using this once it's been developed so
that's that's kind of the goal here um
all
i think there might be a few assumptions
about uh kind of prerequisite plumber
knowledge but i'll try to kind of
highlight some of the main ideas if
there's some unfamiliarity there but
just like i said the use case here is
really simple but i think it will help
us
kind of ignore not necessarily ignore
but it will give us something concrete
that we can work with that's not overly
complex so we can focus instead on how
the the tools working rather than what
we're trying to accomplish with it so
all that being said the idea is i
want to capitalize some text
super easy but and in an r i could do
that with just like the two upper
function that's already there um but to
make this a little bit easier to kind of
think about we're going to write our own
function called caps which takes some
input text
and then we're going to use two upper in
here
on our input text
so again nothing crazy but the idea is
we can give this some sort of string
hello world
and we'll get back the capitalized form
of that now
let's say that for some reason this
functionality is super critical to some
tableau document that i have right i
have a bunch of text and it has to be
capitalized for my executives and this
is the way i'm going to do it now it's a
stretch but that's the that's the
scenario scenario we're going to work
with so the idea is
this function right now just lives in r
and what i really want is first i want
to kind of make this accessible to other
tools generically and then we'll worry
about tableau so the way one of the ways
to do that is to use the plumber package
and to turn this function that we've
defined into an api so i'm going to
bring in plumber now
and then plumber works by
using special comments to change
existing r functions like what we have
written here into apk endpoints that can
respond to common http requests
so it's it's nice in the sense that i
don't necessarily have to write a bunch
of new code to turn this into an api i
just have to add some new comments to do
that so we're going to come in and the
special kind of signifier for plumber is
the standard comment symbol followed by
an asterisk
and then there are these kind of
decorators that begin with the at symbol
that we can use to define different
pieces and components of
what we want plumber to do and how we
want it to handle the functions we
define so i'm going to create an api
title here we'll call this simple
capitolization example
we'll give it a description
capitalized some text
okay so these are this is just a generic
kind of title description for the api
and collection of different endpoints in
our case we're only building this one
function this caps function so i'm going
to create a little description for this
this is capitalize
input text and return the result
and then here's kind of the significant
part here's where i define okay we're
gonna listen for post requests at the
capitalize
path
so here's here's kind of the significant
part where i tell plumber look respond
to these types of requests at this
location and whenever
a request comes in that matches that
criteria this function will be executed
with the contents of that request on a
very kind of simplified way so i'm going
to just go ahead and save this here so
that we can
use some of the rstudio niceties so now
once i've saved this as a plumber file
you'll see that rstudio gives me this
run api option
and if i select this here
we get this cool little interface that
pops up in our in our viewer pane and
this is
a
ui user interface that's been generated
dynamically by plumber in combination
with swagger which is the rendering tool
that's been used here and this shows us
you know here's our here's our title
here's our description and if i change
the values right we see capitalized some
text is is what we see over here and if
i went back and changed that and re-ran
this we'd see the change updated here
and if i come down here to capitalize we
can expand this out we see our input
text here
we see an info some information about
the different types of responses we
might get back and i can actually go
ahead and try this out we can say hello
world
and we can hit execute
and there we go we have our response
back a capitalized form of what the
input that we provided
awesome now at this point like we've
done
like 95 of the work necessary to get
this to work inside of tableau and in
fact if we just take a step back and
kind of ignore tableau for a second and
think about what we've done kind of more
broadly we've taken this function that
we wrote that capitalizes text and we've
kind of turned it into this service that
can be used
regardless of the tool that's using it
right like i could somebody writing
python or somebody writing go or
somebody writing c plus or java or
whatever could call out to this service
and say hey here's some text to
capitalize and then r would execute what
it needs to do and return back the
capitalized text so it made this kind of
very generic interface to our function
which can be super super useful
now at this point if i want to get this
to tableau i have into tableau there's
kind of like a couple of routes i could
go one is i could start figuring out how
exactly tableau wants to communicate
with external services tableau has a
very specific way of sending requests
and and a very specific way in which it
expects responses and i could go through
and i could build out an api that
meets that criteria or meets the
contract that tableau expects in api to
be
or
i could use the plumber tablet package
which does all of that work for me and
so i'm going to go ahead and bring in
plumber tableau now which as the name
suggests is a package that expands the
functionality of plumber to make it easy
to build
apis essentially that that operate as
analytics extensions inside of tab level
so once i bring the plumber tableau
package in there's kind of two
things that i now need to do one is
there's a couple of new annotations that
i need to provide when i describe my
function one is uh tableau arg
and then one
is tableau
return
and and as you can probably kind of
guess from the naming tableau arg is
where we define the arguments that we
expect tableau to be providing in this
case that's this input text argument and
we might have multiple arguments we
could have input text one and input text
two or you know we could have different
things maybe there's parameters again
this is a very simple use case but
perhaps i have
a
a previously trained machine learning
model and i'm expecting tableau to
submit new data and then i'm going to
run that new data through my model and
generate predictions and and then send
the prediction the predicted outcomes
back to tableau for further analysis
in which case i might have you know a
dozen or more different inputs that i
expect to come from tableau and each one
of those can be accompanied by this
tableau our uh this tableau arg
specification here that allows me to
define well some information about that
argument so here we're going to say this
is input text is the name of the
argument and its type is
if i could spell its type is character
right
and then here's a brief description this
is the text we want capitalized
okay
easy enough tableau return is what is my
extension sending back to tableau
i first need to define what type of what
data type i'm sending back so again i'm
going to be sending back a character
value and this is the capitalize
input text okay
so those two new things tableau argon
tableau return and then the last piece
here is i need to add this modifier down
at the bottom and a modifier is simply a
function that that makes changes to an
existing plumber router so here the way
to do that in this context is to use
this plumber decorator
and then we're going to say
tableau extension
and this is a function in fact we can
just look at this really quickly this is
a function that is exported from plumber
tableau it's one of the only functions
that the package actually exports um and
this
there's an example here of how you might
use that in the way that we're using it
here but essentially this function does
all the necessary modification to the
underlying api so that it matches and
behaves the way that tableau wants it to
and the advantage here is this means
that as the as the r developer i don't
need to necessarily worry about how
tableau is communicating with my api i
can trust that the api will communicate
appropriately as long as i use this
modifier once i've defined everything
that i want to define within my api
okay so i'm going to save the file
again just to review we brought in the
plumber tableau package we added tableau
arg and tableau return and we modified
the api with this tableau extension
function
you might notice that i'm not actually
executing the function
and that's just kind of the a semantic
of plumber itself so here is is the
function
name or the function reference i'm not
executing the function but i'm
indicating call this function
on the api that's previously defined and
allow that function to modify the api as
it as it needs to
with these changes in place if i run the
api again
i see basically the same page but
there's a few kind of subtle differences
one is these new links show up here
these are automatically generated as
part of this plumber tableau
package and we won't spend time looking
at them here but we will kind of in a
moment once we transition to
deployment but if i scroll down and open
up my capitalized endpoint again
now things look very different
and the reason is is because one of the
things that that
plumber tableau does is it automatically
will create and generate documentation
about how
tableau is going to interact with this
particular extension as well as an
example request of what tableau is going
to submit so here this this request that
we see here
is in the format that tableau will be
submitting requests tableau submits a
json object with two kind of nested
values script and data and so we see
those referenced here and then the data
object contains the actual data values
that are being passed over from tableau
if we inspect this we can see that that
arg1 is the first value here um
and if we if we look just above this
this table here shows a mapping between
what my function in r has defined and
what tableau is going to submit so we
can see that input text in my r function
corresponds to arc 1
in this tableau data object it's a
character type value and here's a
description of what that value is and
it's not optional and it's a it's a
required field
i can still try this out so i can click
try it out i can come in here and change
the value of arg1 to hello
everyone
execute this and if we scroll down we
see the capitalized version of that text
being returned back
now
i'm going to kind of pause there
and highlight a couple of things one is
as the
like our developer here i haven't
touched tableau i haven't opened tableau
i haven't needed to look at tableau i
haven't needed to visit tableau's
website but regardless of that i've been
able to build an extension and verify
that it will work with tableau because i
have an example of what a tableau
request will look like let me just open
this up one more time right when i click
try it out in here and run this request
and say this
this is a test this is me verifying yep
this extension seems to be doing exactly
what i expected to be doing and i have
confidence that it will behave that way
when it's connected to tableau
so the advantage is i can do all this
within a tool that i'm comfortable and
familiar with in this case i'm using our
studio workbench i might be using our
studio on my desktop i might not be
using our studio i might be developing
this
in some other editor or some other form
but regardless i have access to this
interface either directly in our studio
or in a browser and i can test and
verify
the behavior of my extension without
needing to
either open top below myself or rely on
somebody that has tableau access and
that was one of our goals there's you
know if i if i take a step back and just
look at some of the philosophy that went
into designing plumber tableau part of
this was to say
we want to make things easy for both
both um like populations here one is the
developers how do we make things easy
for them well we build and extend tools
that they're already comfortable and
familiar with which is why we chose to
extend plumber and use that framework
we also make it easy for them to test
validate and confirm the behavior of
things without needing to rely on other
tools which is what we just observed
the other side of this is how do we help
the
tableau user right they might not know
anything about r they might not know
anything about plumber or anything any
of these tools they just are building
tableau workbooks and dashboards and
visualizations and they want access to
the things that have been built here now
in some organizations the r developer
and the tableau developer might be the
same person or might work together on
the same team and other organizations
they may have no idea who one another
are right it might be two totally
separate groups two totally separate
individuals um and we wanted that to
we wanted to support that type of
distinction between these two roles
okay
now
at this point i have a fully functioning
running
tableau extension that i've built in r
the problem is tableau cannot access it
at this point right and now if i was
running let's say for example i was
running um our studio desktop and i had
to have low desktop i could stitch these
things together like i could run the api
inside of our studio desktop i could
open up tableau desktop i can configure
them to speak to one another and that
would be great but that's like a very
limited utility because it's still just
everything's still local to me right
everything's still running on my desktop
and i'm not gonna like pass my laptop
around the department to give people
access to my dashboard i need some sort
of centralized hosting mechanism
on the tableau side that's either going
to be tableau online or tableau server
on the our the our side
the easiest way to distribute and share
and provide access to this extension is
through our studio connect
and our studio connect is a publishing
platform that supports publishing all
kinds of different r and python content
including these tableau extensions like
the one that we've built here and in
order to publish this to to rco connect
i can select this little publish button
here inside of the rstudio development
environment i can click publish
api and then select details about where
i want to publish it the name of it
things like that
now i've already gone through and
published this api or one very similar
to it so i'm going to just open that now
so i'm going to comment r studio connect
let me navigate to
this particular api and there there was
no we'll notice there's a few subtle
differences here in what we look at
in terms of the title and description of
the api but the behavior
and everything like that is the same
so this is this is the that same api
that we were just working with now
published on our studio connect and
something that you'll immediately notice
is this looks very different than what
we saw before right when we ran this
inside of our studio we saw an interface
that looked like this if you've done any
sort of api development or api work
before you're likely familiar with this
type of interface it's a very common way
of
kind of exposing the functionality of an
api as well as providing mechanisms for
testing and validating the api and so
this is
a very kind of developer-centric view of
what i've built
on the other side once we publish the
star studio connect we're now kind of
switching gears and saying okay now
we're not necessarily trying to give the
developer tools anymore
but rather we're trying to expose this
in a way that's intuitive for
the tableau user to know what they need
to do and they don't need to know how
the api request is formed they don't
need to know how the endpoint responds
what they need to know is how do i use
this
extension
from
tableau
and so if we look at this document
that's been pulled up here on our studio
connect we can see that's exactly what
this is trying to provide it gives the
same you know title description that we
saw previously and then it has this
usage section here
that defines it it's a literal copy and
paste here's how you use this inside of
tableau copy this script function into
your tableau workbook under a calculated
field
make it change to the input value to
match what you're trying to provide from
tableau and you're good to go and we'll
take a look at that just a moment and if
we scroll down a little bit further we
see
additional information about the
arguments that we're
expecting tableau to provide as well as
the return value that we're going to be
giving back to tableau and again all
this is being powered by those
additional annotations that we added
when we introduced plumber tableau to
our api
one thing that i'll note is that if we
come back just for a moment to our
development environment and take a look
when we defined tableau return we not
only described what we're returning but
we were very specific about the type of
data that we're going to be returning
and the reason for that is because if we
come back now to rcdo connect you'll see
that the script function is strongly
typed right this is a script function
and then this str is a reference to the
fact that we expect a string value to
come back from the extension
so because we because we provided
information when we developed this that
said hey we're going to return a
character value we know when we generate
this documentation that we should put
script string as the script function
using this particular extension and this
again the idea is just convenience we
wanted to make this as easy as possible
for the tableau user for them to come in
copy and paste this into their tableau
workbook so let's do that let's do this
in action i'm going to grab this this
script that we have here we're going to
open up a new
workbook on tableau online
i'm going to zoom out i've got to
connect to a data source so i'll just
connect to the default one
i'm going to zoom in here a little bit
just so we can see a little bit better
um first thing i'm going to do is just
save this
because in order to use analytics
extensions we have to have a saved
workbook
go ahead and save that
and then i'm going to
now create a parameter
we'll call this input text
and this is this just gives us something
that we can kind of in real time work
with and see so we're going to say this
is a string
the current values hello world
go ahead and hit ok there
and then let's
actually
show this parameter so over here on the
right hand side we have this input text
field and we can we can use this field
to input anything
that's referenceable from our tablet
workbook and the significance now is we
can now go through the process of
creating a calculated field we'll call
this caps and here's where we're going
to paste in
that script function that we've copied
from our studio connect and you'll
notice the first argument here is
the location of this extension on our
studio connect right so this is the path
to the extension as hosted on our studio
connect and then the second and any
subsequent arguments are the values or a
reference to the values that we want to
pass from tableau to the extension
so i'm going to replace string value
with input text
which is a reference to our parameter
that we created and then hit ok
and now we're going to bring this
calculated field into our workbook so
take a moment to load and then we're
gonna it automatically defaults to a
color value but we don't want that we'll
call this so we'll change this to be a
label and here we can see and there's a
way to expand it and i remember how but
if we hover we can see the capitalized
rendered text of hello world and just to
showcase that it doesn't just do hello
world we can come over and say this is
an
extension
and if we hover again we see
this is an analytics extension in in
full capitalization
so we've gone through the full process
of we've developed this extension inside
of
our studio or some other editor using
plumber and plumber tableau we've
published the extension to rstudio
connect where it can then be accessed
and used by tableau users who have to
come in
let me come back to our studio connect
come in copy the script value paste it
into their workbook under a calculated
field and then supply the appropriate
values to that to that extension
function and in our case that
appropriate value if i pull this up one
more time
that an appropriate value is this input
text typically right again a very very
kind of trivial example so in in
practice what we might see here is we
might see something like you know
multiple values being passed in from the
underlying data source that my tableau
workbook is built on top of and then and
then we get really nice functionality
where if a user comes in and filters the
data or changes the view or otherwise
manipulates the underlying data that
triggers this extension to to reevaluate
with new data so it's this is a very
responsive real-time interaction between
some third-party service in our case
that third-party services are studio
connect that's hosting this this r
script that's our function that we're
running uh and it's responding in real
time to how users are interacting with
the tablet workbook
just to kind of highlight that let me
come back here
so here's an example let me see if this
will pull up and render it sometimes
it's a little bit finicky but we'll see
if we can
make something happen so here's an
example of
kind of something that's a little bit
more involved right so we have once this
pulls up here um we have two different
actually two different extensions that
are being hosted on our studio connect
one is an r extension
that does real-time outlier detection
giving us given a set of input data so
we consider a this is a transactional
data
set that we're working with here so we
consider
sales and profit for a given customer
and then based on sales and profit we
determine which customers appear to be
outliers given the totality of the data
set
that all happens in r then we have a
another extension written in python so
there's a kind of a
companion package to plumber tableau
called fast api tableau that does the
same thing just on the python side and
so we have another extension written in
python in fact let me just pull that up
while that's loading
uh and this extension takes a previously
trained model
some input from tableau and uses that
input to generate new predicted values
and that allows us to do something in
the case of our workbook what we're
doing is we're saying okay given what we
know about this customer and
transactional history
what amount of profit do we predict out
of this customer service transaction uh
and so we take that predicted profit
value we compared to the actual profit
of the transaction and then we can
identify under and over performers based
on that metric of comparing predicted
date to realize profit let me
just open up that example here okay so
this
this view is a little bit different than
what we had seen previously and the
reason for this is the the fast api
tableau package is has a slightly
different interface when it when it
comes to rendering the documentation
that we generate for tableau users and
there will be an update that gets made
to the plumber tableau package that
brings a similar style interface there
as well so there's a kind of more
unified feeling between the two but we
see the same behavior here we can come
in and we can say using tableau
workbooks same thing we can copy and
paste this this value into our tablet
workbook we have a description of what
we're doing and the values we're
expecting
if i come back to tableau here let me
see if i can
get this to work this i just wanted to
showcase like what it might look like in
a more comprehensive example um and so
we should we should be able to get this
to come through here in a minute it just
takes a minute to wake tableau up
sometimes
so if i come in here i just want to
highlight this is we had sometimes it
has a problem rendering but if i look at
this
description of this particular extension
we can see here i'm referencing you know
again the location of the extension
itself as a as it relates to our studio
connect and then here are the actual
values that i'm passing in from my from
my workbook to tableau so i have five
different values that i'm passing in
here these are all inputs to the
to the model that i trained and then
those values get used on the connect
side or on the on the extension side to
generate new predicted values when it
comes to profit and and return that
value back into here um
yeah and i think because we restarted we
reset the the um extension in the middle
of this it timed out so i wasn't able to
complete its trip um anyway so that's
like at a very kind of like i said kind
of simplistic level that's the idea
behind plumber tableau and by extension
fast api tableau is to say look let's
say that i have some
business logic i have some complex
arithmetic or machine learning or
whatever the case is that i need to do
as some sort of like real-time
interaction with my tableau workbook
takes place and and whatever it is that
i'm trying to do extends beyond what
tableau natively gives me in terms of
capabilities right and that's often the
case when it comes to machine learning
there's some rudimentary machine
learning capabilities in tableau but if
i'm looking to do something a little bit
more complex or involved or something
like outlier detection which is one of
the examples that we provide in our
online repository then
this becomes a really compelling use
case because i can essentially say like
i'm going to take the data that i have
in tableau i'm going to send it off
somewhere for something to be done to it
and then i'm going to get the results
back and
in this case we've shown i can send that
data off to our studio connect this
extension can execute and then return
the results back into tableau and i can
then further use those results to
you know improve my analysis or
enhance my visualization or you know
whatever i'm doing with the results once
they come back
is up to me
there's a few caveats that i think are
worth pointing out one is tableau is
kind of interesting um
in in the sense that if i'm passing in
you know this this is a pretty again
trivial to example but if i'm if i'm
referencing a large underlying data set
and i'm trying to pass that data set in
bulk to my extension
it depends on how i'm actually
calculating my calculated field inside
of tableau
because tableau will either send one
request with all the data or it will
send one request per observation which
can dramatically slow things down so
imagine i've got 100 000 rows of data um
i can and accidentally if i if i
haven't set things up the right way i
could accidentally end up sending 100
000 requests every time i try to use the
extension and that's certainly going to
be much less efficient than sending just
one request with a hundred thousand
observations and so there's we have some
documentation around things to look into
and how to kind of go about reasoning
around how how to set up tableau so that
it sends a request
along the appropriate dimension so that
you end up working as efficiently as
possible
the one other thing that i'll mention
that we haven't discussed so far is how
do we set these things up from you know
like how do we set up the connection
between tableau and our studio connect
and that that's kind of a little bit
beyond the scope of like plumber tableau
itself but i think it's worth just kind
of understanding how that works
so if i come back to the home page of
tableau online and come to settings as
an admin in tableau online if i come
over to extensions
here's where i can do a couple things
one i can enable analytics extensions so
about halfway down the page there's
analytics extensions i would choose to
enable those for my site and then
there isn't anything preconfigured so i
need to create a new connection from
this
from this option list i'll select
analytics extensions api which is the
final option and then in here we can say
we can give it a name our studio connect
provide the hostname
irstudioconnect.com and the port
whatever that might be your username is
always our studio dash connect
and then the password here is any valid
rstudio connect user api key
um and the thing to understand about
this setup again two things one is
this is this is managed and done by the
tableau administrators so individual
users aren't managing connections at
this level this is down to the
administrative level and then when you
create a workbook as a user you can
select which connection you want to
actually use from that workbook
so
it's done by the administrator the other
thing is this password is centrally used
and what i mean by that is whatever api
key is is input here by the tableau
admin is the key that will be used
anytime an extension uses this
connection
so if this key is like my own personal
key that means my personal r studio
connect user has to be added to every
extension that is published in order for
it to be used from tableau
our recommended approach here is to
create like a service account called
tableau or tableau extension or
really call it whatever you want but
then use a an api key from that service
account as the key view that you provide
here in the setup on tableau
and then add that tableau user again
whatever you you happen to have called
that service account add that user to
every extension that's published so that
they have
so the tableau has the ability to call
out to that extension
okay and i think like again
a trivial example in terms of what we're
actually doing but but hopefully
highlights the
kind of the flexibility of this approach
and and the way in which it can be used
to extend the functionality of tableau
beyond just what's already there um
anyway but that's that's kind of plumber
tableau in a in a nutshell
[Music]